I'm going to start off in a bit of a
strange spot which is that for thinking
about division I want us to begin by
thinking about multiplication
multiplication and division are two
sides of the same coin
okay just looking at different angles so
if we know stuff at that multiplication
which we do right we can use that to
understand division so let's just do
this this products
okay can we work out what this is can
you talk me through how you might do it
okay pause okay six times three how away
with our tables in fact I think I've got
a cup it like what is it you can 18 very
good so what I do that okay well done so
I think most people are comfortable with
that even if you did a different way I
think you'd still end up with 318 okay
so here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
borrow this family of numbers and use
them to demonstrate how to do division
okay and some of you I hope I've seen
this before but that's okay we'll all
get on the same page um so I want to
work out 318 divided by six
now we know what the answer is it's
right there okay but why sure all of you
are talked about in in the book mark how
it's important to set things out
properly I'm going to show you how I
would set this out okay so have you
really all of this down here's the way
I'm going to approach this right
okay hands up if you see a symbol or
shape like this before
I'm not straightening and it's up
straight okay I stand it hands down so
we will be able to go through this in a
lip right what do we do here I'm
reversing this process so I want to say
you're not multiplying but how many
sixes can I fit in each part of the
number right no not a trick question
how many sixes can I fit into three yeah
I can't feel any sixes integrated right
so bad luck but that's okay if zero is
how many sixes I see it and it's you're
always well I'm gonna write down there's
my first step okay so it's just like oh
that's cute okay so this guy comes along
for the ride remember I didn't get to
use that three Ryo isn't very useful but
that's okay I'm gonna hold on to him it
tags along just like this one tagged
longer for five to four okay but in a
slightly different way so this is 31 now
this number 31 how many sixes can I fit
31 doesn't say Feli fine very good so
I've got five sixes in there but then I
bought a kind of number hanging you off
so I'm gonna write a five that I've used
and then I got extra one it was sort of
nodding off along here now I get to the
end
how many sixes are eighteen yes three
very good and I've reached the end which
of course we knew as we can sir right
very good now let's extend this a little
bit this is a nice town market went in
evenly divided right so let's have a go
at this
some of you might be able to see this
number is not going to go neatly it's
not going to divide perfectly by five
next lesson we'll talk about exactly why
we can see that it's something without
doing any work but to begin I'm going to
put in my notation here so you can see
division happening and I'm going to ask
the same questions okay how many fives
can I fit into one yes my dear again
thank you so I'm gonna write zero up
there the one because I didn't use it it
sort of comes along for the ride yeah so
how many fives cannot fit into 19 yes
real I can fit three now what sort of
taken three of the fives out it's 15 in
total so what gets left after is number
growing four very good so that's what's
left over and I'm going to continue this
process until I get to the end okay
so let's actually just quickly do this
how many fives in 46 yeah nine five and
there's how much leftover is one left
over and lastly how many fives in 14 two
and there is room now there's four left
over and I've got no more spots to put
them in so I put them up here I write an
earth to say that's what's remaining
that's what's left over the remain one
and I've done it's a 392 is very okay
now we will talk a little bit about what
we end up doing with this for they don't
we can do a few different things with it
for now I'm happy just to leave it there
it's the remainder cuz it now you have
another color please label with me there
are one two three four parts of what
we've just written and they will have
names it's great to have names for
things because then you can describe
round the same hey you know it's that
thing with the guy in the place and no
one has idea what you're talking about
okay so they all have names let's
describe you don't know what the five is
called something
yeah to devise a very good it's what you
are dividing by okay there's another
thing that subsidy this one he it's kind
of very similar names into a yeah he's
nobody there
it's the timid end right some of your
parents might go chant and dividends are
things get shared out to everyone right
that literally shared it's a big sum of
money and it gets divided up for a whole
bunch of people then we've got two last
things one that starts with Q and one
which I think you arena it starts with
ah what do the easy one first starting
with our is remain on and the last word
your funny one starting with Q grammar
question fantastic language is all about
trying to be able to communicate an idea
not just in my head but to you so we all
know what we're talking about it's that
time we give names obviously I just want
to point out I remember we started with
the review questions right everything
you know about multiplication all these
things will come in handy is from divine
life as I thought well how many fives
are in 46 if you know what nine times
five is you can do that just like that